you have a startup that teaches
anti-racism yeah but define your
anti-racism because it's not the same as
like ibrahim kennedy's right no
so ibrahim kennedy defines
racism as basically the presence of
inequity so he defines inequity as
material outcomes between groups
so if there's a difference in outcomes
between different races then that's
proof of racial inequity and that's
proof of racism whereas our
understanding of racism is psychological
we understand that racism or supremacist
ways of thinking occur when an
individual or group of people experience
some kind of insecurity and then project
that insecurity onto others in order to
feel worthy and our our approach teaches
people how to practice dealing with
themselves in a holistic healthy way so
that they will be less likely to
overcompensate
interesting so what do you what so uh
what do you think about critical race
there i know you're not a big fan
what i mean i really don't think about
critical race theory i have to be honest
with you um and there are probably many
different reasons for that uh
you know as i said i've said this before
the show but i try not to be counter
dependent in my identity because that's
also a form of dependence people tend to
think that codependence is the only form
of dependence but actually counter
dependence is also a form so counter
dependence is when your identity is
dependent upon countering someone else
or something else
i you know i'm not a fan of critical
race theory because i'm not a fan of
post-modernism i think that there's no
transcendence at the heart of
post-modernism i think that
post-modernism has a point in that it
critiques
dominant
structures in society which are
susceptible to corruption just just by
nature of being
but the problem is that it becomes
parasitic and begins to eat itself and
so there's no actual transcendence at
the heart of it so i'm critical of
critical theory in general
but i don't really think about credit
cory theory because i'm just trying to
get our anti-racism program out there if
you avoid counter dependence how why do
you say you're anti-racist this is a
great question i love this question
because we define racism not as a
another person or as a
analysis of outcome but as a state of
being
racism is a defect in
relational ways of being you're not
relating to yourself properly and you're
not relating to others properly and so
to be able to counter that presupposes
adopting a set of practices a kind of
lifestyle
and i think in that sense it's less
parasitic because at the heart of it
where you're trying to reach is
transcendence
do you like meditation and stuff yeah
oh cool well how would you define racism
then
um again for me racism is a kind of
relational defect
and it happens when a person is not in
the right relationship with themselves
so they're feeling a lack of
self-worth or contempt or
um but so like how does that present
itself in in society for instance right
so just just to clarify you have you
know iran kennedy's view about inequal
outcomes yeah you have the dictionary
definition of prejudice or
discrimination positively or negative on
the basis of race yeah i would say that
we're more of that of that uh latter
definition but we're also more
interested in psychological
underpinnings of what causes that
prejudice what drives that prejudice in
the first place and where's that
prejudice coming from uh from again a
deep psychological perspective so like
if a guy was walking down the street in
l.a and kicked a a a piece of the
sidewalk that was up and busted his toe
and was like ah who's supposed to fix
these sidewalks and looks and it's like
i bet it was this race of people and
looks and those workers in the city tend
to be percentagely mostly a certain race
yeah and then they're like i knew it
it's that race like yeah what's that
person is not well with themselves and
then you'd have to go deep into their
individual psychology just like what
happened to you when you were a kid why
are you blaming people for kicking yeah
what's going on what's going on here
there's something going on there's
something else going on here but so so
here's my issue right with the reason
why i do
you know think critical race theory is
bad or i i should say
critical race and i also think it's bad
by the way i'm just not
the reason i do focus on it is because i
think it's over at racism yeah well but
again that's that's what we ultimately
that's the beauty of it that's what we
ultimately tackle because it doesn't
matter whether you're black or white you
could be feeling some kind of weird
self-worth issues and project and they
command it can manifest in different
ways but that's ultimately what's at the
heart of it that's all in a way we're
kind of addressing critical reasons i
love that
yeah because when you think about these
young people and their animosity and the
things they they project
you know it's rooted in this
misunderstanding of what race is and
then a projected anger towards certain
race so when i when i when i look at
like critical race theory and applied
principles i think they're they're
overtly racist they want they certainly
against asian people who are a small
minority in this country but yes also
against white people they they blame
someone else but many of many passionate
critical race theorists are white so
what do you think is going on with that
well uh
i think it's it's a lot of these people
it's tribal
so uh ibrahim kennedy for instance yeah
he's his his belief is basically that if
there's a law or policy that creates an
an eq any an equal outcome based on race
it's a racist systemically racist policy
yet when it comes to new york's vaccine
mandates which disproportionately impact
black people in new york he's nowhere to
be found yeah because his whole thing is
actually more
you know i'll put it this way
i would i would i would say i think he
believes a lot of what he says yeah but
i think he's i think so too i think he's
sitting there going yeah but i'm not
going to challenge this one instance
where it's happening because the people
who pay me also like that too
i i don't know but i'm but i'm what what
i'm wondering is i get all that but you
just said criticism are
tribal and they're like anti-white
people but a lot of the people who buy
into this are white so
so what's
what's going on there
they're tribalistically espousing an
ideology regardless of their own race
they're trying and in fact they say
things like as a white person i
recognize these things because they care
more about what their tribe says than
about who they are what they experience
and what the actual problem so what is
their tri who is their tribe who belongs
to their tribe there's so in the in the
culture war it's very strange but there
is very overarching tribe you know
tribal factions there's the left and the
right but that doesn't actually get to
the heart of what the factions are so
bill maher is considered to be kind of
in the left but he's kind of in the
middle of the culture war because he's
very anti-woke he's very critical of of
the booster shots
but he despises trump yeah and so he's
kind of in the middle on the right you
actually have liberals people who are
economically left sure it's it's it's
it's all scrambled
yes but it may actually just be
authoritarian versus libertarian in a
large way not completely not not
completely because you certainly have
people on the right who are
authoritarian
who are
you know yeah defying critical race
theory you know what i mean yeah yeah
but there's like a big component of it
is uh authoritarian versus libertarian
it may have a lot to do with
individualist versus collectivist but
again not absolute because there are
elements of the fringe far right ultra
you know
uh nationalists they're called their you
know collectivist in a certain to a
certain degree okay so it's it's
it really is hard to to figure it out
but i would say it's kind of like yin
yang you know what i mean it's not like
there's two equal spaces that are
opposing each other it's like they
actually swirl around and have you know
similarities and differences
when i when i look at uh like candy and
i look at um robin d'angelo but also
just the democratic party there's
something that's very you know very
obvious in that there is a substantive
lack of prince substantial lack of
principles and you know to i'll shout
out texas for instance for instance they
did the the the heartbeat bill okay and
all of a sudden we have people screaming
my body my choice okay yeah once again
i'll throw it back to new york i'm like
yo what about them mandating vaccines
because i'm pro-choice you know even
though i don't like abortion i think
it's bad and i agree with a lot of
conservatives on their on their
suppositions the the problem is the
government intervening for medical
reasons and it's like a very scary
getting into nuance is difficult but i
look at texas and i'm like yeah i i
understand the exemptions i don't like
having to go to the government for a
medical you know something has to do
with a very serious embarrassing
humiliating or troubling medical
procedure
i'ma say the same thing about new york
city but all of a sudden now i see this
establishment and this like left faction
in the culture war
has no interest in defending bodily
autonomy or racist policy which is the
vaccine mandate new york city
so when it comes to throw it back to
what we were talking about yeah the
overwhelming amount of white people who
are anti-white i think it's mostly
because they don't care about the ideas
if they did they my buddy my choice
would mean vax mandates too what they
care about is just being part of a
collective that vise for power it kind
of it makes me think of
self-flagellation like a religious
because we try to talk about a metaphor
like this sort of religion there's this
lack of religion in society so we've
kind of some people have adopted a new
faith and yeah people would beat
themselves on the back with uh with
whips and stuff as part of like the self
flagellation like i'm suffering i'm so
horrible original sin i'm a sinner
punished i must punish myself so that
i'm not punished in hell or whatever
yeah and i think these people kind of
have that same like self-punishment
mindset i don't know if this
self-flagellation is just part of the
human psyche that needs to be i think
there's agitated from time to time or
something i think there's a few
different things definitely it's like
working out you know a few different
things happening here some of these
people the less prominent you know white
uh people who are anti-white probably
don't actually care but they're scared
they want to fit in there are several
prominent activists who were always on
the left but the left as of today is
fundamentally different from the left of
10 years ago okay so uh my my favorite
shout out is to rap news by juice media
they had a video 10 years ago if it was
in end of 2010 where oh man it's almost
11 years ago now where they say you know
hillary clinton is is bad alex jones is
calling out the kami nazi fascists the
the the the uh
you know the the democrats and the
republicans the establishment are trying
to turn back the clock on freedom of
speech and all that stuff and i'm like
wow if you were to make that today you'd
be a trump supporter if you said hillary
clinton is bad and we had free speech
julian assange is good and alex jones is
speaking the truth
that was 10 years ago that was the left
yeah so there's been this very serious
shift a lot of people all of a sudden
are just like jay leno said it the other
day you know jay leno story came out jay
leno said either you you get in line
with the woke or die mm-hmm so the
that's do you think that's true
no absolutely not okay i mean if you
want to be jay leno and be on tv
yes right we're lucky enough that there
exists an economic space where this show
can function but if the internet didn't
exist
these conversations would be happening
in secret but if the internet didn't
exist
would any of this be what any of this be
happening probably not so right it's a
double-edged sword but but to be fair
something else would be happening right
you know before yeah war for instance
you know iraq war lies in the media so
it's
factions emerged
we avoided 1984 because we had the
internet the whole like
never ending war overseas where it's a
different enemy and then now you're
fighting a different enemy one day and
all of a sudden 20 years later they're
like and now we've always been at war
with your eastern you know did you ever
read 1984 yeah and so we that would have
been afghanistan and iraq but since we
had the internet we saw it all oh we
were like nope just to mention so the
first group i think are people who are
scared i should say the first group but
there's a group of people who are scared
and they'll just be like whatever you
say leave me out of it then you have
true believers who are just white people
who are like wow i can't believe this is
what you know
has really happened and i'm woke i've
awakened the world and you have grifters
i i genuinely think robin d'angelo is a
grifter like i think you don't think she
believes what she's writing absolutely
not okay why do you why don't you think
she believes it i think fundamentally uh
her ideologies at least the way she
espouses it is absolutely contradictory
if so if you are a white person who
believes white people should step back
but plenty of people believe
contradictory things yeah i know yeah
genuinely and so that's a cognitive
dissonance where i challenge i will
challenge someone's uh
you know whether they actually believe
something and boy do people go nuts when
they when they realize it one example of
the difference between me and someone
like that is yeah i had been saying for
a while that look i think if a business
wants to mandate vaccines depending on
the scale of that business i think it's
actually fine because i don't want to
impose my will on a mom-and-pop shop
where it's like an older guy and he's
like look i'm hiring two or three people
i want them to be vaccinated i'm like i
don't want to infringe on the rights of
just some regular working-class dude
yeah then a week later i said it is the
people of new york who are upholding the
edict making this happen if the regular
people said no to the mandates all of
this would stop and then i said well
certainly both of those ideas can't be
true so perhaps it's wrong for
businesses to manage their employees get
the vaccine okay as opposed to what we
see with the no my body my choice people
where they completely just say f you i'm
not going to argue about new york it
doesn't exist to me or they won't even
bring it yeah but i don't think that
makes a person a grifter not to be
semantical
i just i that doesn't make you a grifter
i suppose i suppose i can then say about
d'angelo is that based on what i've
heard from her and seen from her i just
believe she's lying okay like i do not
feel that what she says is genuine i
have no idea
so fair enough
yeah i mean it's all uh trying to
read people i guess yeah and
i think she had a heart hard childhood
yeah and i think that plays a huge role
elaborate well i read in passing
somewhere that she her father wasn't in
the picture abandoned the family she
grew up in
going from like moving constantly and
also her mother was sort of incompetent
and she dealt with issues of abandonment
and identity issues at a very young age
and i am like i have almost no doubt
that that is playing a huge role in in
all of this
so it's possible she's just not that
smart
or and or it's possible that she is
spiritually suffering and this is how
it's manifesting high intelligence but
with a lot of pain that's a very
dangerous recipe too i don't think she
does anakin skywalker
well so how do you how do you deal with
that you know how do you well you have
very prominent people very wealthy
people in big institutions that are
implementing these these ideas
at an ever escalating rate of you know
well you i think i think one of the ways
you deal with it is you
you guard yourself as much as possible
from
from falling prey to
some of the uh
shortcomings and
um
i guess
blind spots and but you don't do that
simply by
propositional
exposition of facts who's right who's
wrong but you actually do it by
recognizing the complexity of the human
condition your capacity to fall prey to
that your capacity to
uh
become susceptible to that way of
thinking and the pr and giving yourself
the practices required to not fall prey
to it because it's so easy to fall prey
to it in a in a way what are some of
those practices
meditation
for sure
shadow work from like carl young's
philosophy
shadow work is when you
you recognize what's triggering your ego
usually our egos are triggered by other
people when they're doing something that
we don't like
that and that thing is present within us
now there's a difference between saying
to a person your behavior is reckless
your behavior is problematic and saying
to that same person who engaged in that
reckless behavior that you're trash
those are two very different things once
you start engaging in the latter kind of
vocabulary you set yourself up on a
pedestal and you set yourself up as
better than that person as if that
behavior is foreign to you as if you're
not capable of engaging in that same
behavior and you've actually started
down the path of supremacist ways of
thinking in the literal sense you think
that you're supreme you think that
you're superior to that person so you do
shadow work by you can do it in
many ways but one of the ways you can do
it is noticing when your ego is
triggered and recognizing how the
behavior that someone else engaged in or
the impulse that someone else is
operating out of is also existing within
you and you'll see that same behavior
the next time you'll still say it's
reckless and problematic but your ego
won't be triggered by it so you'll be
less likely to other that person when
you critique that person and then i
would imagine your criticisms will be
more likely to be taken by them exactly
they'll be able to receive it more
likely to receive it there's no
guarantee anything but there's there
will be more likely to receive it sounds
like we just need to replace crt with
philosophy yeah
yes self-reflection yeah
i mean that's that's our motto yeah yeah
so instead
i think what we end up getting is
too many people in the united states
don't want to be involved in any of this
yeah fighting is hard it's taxing and i
think you can look to the animal kingdom
fighting is never the first choice
so here's something here's something
interesting the the like the aggression
of an animal can be determined on where
it lives or where it operates so uh
burrowing animals for instance
when they're in when you encounter them
in a burrow they will fight you they're
aggressive they have one dimension to
move in they i so there's no escaping
birds don't attack you because birds can
just leave and leaving is way easier
so what ends up happening for regular
people is that
there are vested interests in spreading
crt and it's it's ideology there's money
to be made for sure
there are true believers there are
people who are scared of just going
along with it thinking they'll fit in
and then corporations say look this is
what's on social media we think this
plays well i don't you know we don't
want to rock the boat and then it
creates the social pressure where over
time people are just like i don't want a
fight so they give in to the most
aggressive ideology and that leads us
down a very very dark and authoritarian
path but then that thing actually blows
up in their faces and then they come
call us
no but i mean many in many cases they've
they've brought in crt into the staff
into the training of their people it
wreaks havoc in the workplace
and then they have to start all over
again do you have any specific examples
like a story you don't get to name the
companies or anything like that but you
want to like give us an example um
[Music]
i mean i can just tell you in general we
do we do demo interviews with companies
all the time and they report back to us
it's a very like simple script that they
report back to us and it's repeated all
the time we brought in this very
typical
approach to diversity and inclusion
training and it did not go over well and
now we are trying to figure out what to
do and we heard you on some podcasts but
like how does that is the life cycle
well like many cases just like what
happened
specifically like like people were
self-segregated the diversity consultant
told them to segregate themselves based
upon race a lot of people don't like
that oh yeah that's standard that's
standard the consultant tells them or
just assumes the lived experiences of
all these people based upon skin color a
lot of people black and white don't like
that so i wouldn't underestimate the
amount of
rumblings that may be happening in these
companies even though they're not
necessarily you're not necessarily
seeing that on twitter but it's
definitely happening that makes me laugh
and it kind of makes me happy yeah the
like to hear that the things that we see
as bad for the reasons we see it as bad
are being reported back to you as that
they are bad and they don't work yes and
it's like it's like vindicating yeah but
it's also cool that you guys can come in
and kind of fix that yeah try to so what
would you what advice would you have
like how do you work with a company that
contacts you
we so we have online courses but we also
have workshops ultimately we are a
startup and we're trying to get to the
place where we can
create a
suite of practices for organizations so
you know a one-time workshop and our
workshops are pretty dope i have to say
but it's like a full day workshop and
that doesn't translate into sustainable
practice it's just not the nature of a
workshop so what we want to ultimately
do is get our stuff into
as of training uh into the learning
management systems of corporations so
that when they're onboarding their
employees they can use our practices
eventually be able to
service them with some of our coaches
who can check in to make sure they're
doing those self-awareness practices
throughout the months weeks quarters et
cetera um so ultimately we want people
to start practicing i mean the the
emphasis is on the practice i had a
conversation
recently with someone who was talking
about policy and they were like we wrote
a statement because this is also very
popular as i'm sure you know like let's
make a statement about how we are
super anti-racist and
and i'm like that's not a policy that's
a statement a policy is a set of
practices that an institution operates
according to so we can have a long-term
conversation about what those practices
should look like again with the with the
objective of affording that sense of
self-awareness um not overcompensating
for your insecurities creating a culture
of belonging we can actually talk about
how to create those practices but what
you have this is not a policy it's just
a statement i i remember that famous
george carlin sketch where he just goes
on stage and says every single racial
slur he can think of and then he
actually calls eddie murphy and richard
pryor the n-word which like before my
time yeah i mean i think it was like
early 90s how old are you i'm 28. oh
okay so
maybe
i was probably too young to watch two
years old but it might have been like
94. i was one years old right exactly
but uh
you know even even when i see that i'm
like wow i can't believe he would even
jokingly say that about these guys yeah
but everyone in the crowd laughs
there was no big controversy over him
doing it because the point he was making
when he said it was that
you need to understand the person behind
the words because the words themselves
don't affect you sticks and stones
etcetera so i i mean because i wonder in
a lot of these corporate settings
someone might say an off-caller joke you
know without the intent to actually
demean someone yeah but then someone
might get offended by triggering these
sessions yeah someone well i don't i
don't think that's what's triggering
primarily you don't think so no like
we've heard stories about people who are
like oh i said a joke at work and now
they're making me go to like a diversity
training i think that's a lot i think
that like companies are conservative and
they're like oh we don't want you to sue
us so that's why they're doing that i
don't think it's like driven by any real
thing no i completely agree with you i
just i just mean like uh oh someone said
a naughty word we might get sued quick
put them in a diversity training to
protect ourselves yeah but i don't think
i agree but unfortunately or fortunately
whatever the end of critical race theory
doesn't solve for that problem because
the institutions will always be like
that right
not to mention crt segregates people
which i think makes that worse yeah well
it does make it worse yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time